the challenge that I've found when
people have done this to me is that the
notes go faster than you can write
because I'm not writing them okay so for
that reason I'm gonna go through them
slowly enough but I do want you to ride
them with me because I think it will
help you actually absorb it into your
brain okay so make a subheading
somewhere and then you can make the
title of that subheading the sum of a
geometric progression just might look
like we looked at the sum of an
arithmetic progression yesterday and I
want you have a look at how I've set
this up part of why I'm doing it like
this is because I'm dropping you into
the deep end last time we had a look at
actual numbers but I'm going straight
for the algebra now so I'm I'm only
talking by the way to sort of kill time
for you as you write what you can see on
the screen we're considering a geometric
progression there could be anything it
could have any first term it could have
any ratio but if it is a geometric
progression then the difference I should
say the ratio from one term to the next
will always be R so you can see I've got
the second term being AR that the
external on being AR squared Y is my
last term got n minus 1 why is that yeah
we're not this guy doesn't have any R's
on it right so this is turn number n on
the end all right so let's have a think
about this guy now like we said before
we denote a sum with all mrs. Lee's can
we slow the fans down a little bit thank
you we denote this song with an S you'll
sometimes see a textbook and call this a
partial sum because well you go to a
certain part of this usually don't go
forever okay we'll get to that later
what I want to do with this is try and
understand how can we play a similar
kind of algebraic trick like with Divya
with the arithmetic progression so I can
write this in a succinct way okay so
he's my first question I've got my dot
dot dot which indicates some number of
terms in here for reasons that become
clear in a second I actually want not
just the last term but I want to write
down the term before it and you're gonna
write this on your next line what would
be the term immediately before this one
won't be the term before what do you
think exactly
hey our and - - how does a key get air -
- what did he do to this term to get
that term but he just said did he add
one uh I think he actually did the
opposite of it I think he subtracted
think about this right I'm trying to go
from one term to the previous term yeah
yeah so if I went forward I'd add one
but in fact if I subtract one from this
I get n minus two are you with me so far
okay so there is an N minus two hiding
there I just chose to include it in the
dot dot dot okay so you want to have
this on your next line now what I want
to do with this line which is your
second line of working okay is I want to
make it so I can collapse this together
I want to be able to simplify things out
and I have like a bunch of terms here it
won't do to just turn it backwards like
I did yesterday you can make a copy of
it and turn it backwards it ends up
being not very useful here's what I'm
going to do the trick with the
arithmetic progression had to do with
addition because it was a series that we
made from adding this is a series that
we've made from multiplication so my
trick is going to be to do with
multiplication I'm gonna take every
single term on this line by the way I'm
just talking to kill time so you can
write the whole line and I'm going to
multiply through by that common ratio by
our okay just before I show you what
it's going to be think about what you
predict happens next when you multiply
every term by our how will they be
different how will the indices change
hmm when you multiply by the same base
what do you do with the indices if I had
say let me get this again if I had say 2
to the power of 3 times 2 to the power
of 7 what do you do with those indices
you add right you add what those indices
are now I'm multiplying by AR to the
power of 1 so that means what should I
do - every indicee i should add one
which is indeed what you get is this is
this what you predicted yeah so every
term you can see the index of R is just
sort of pushed up 1 ok all right now why
is this useful to me why is this useful
to you perhaps you're seeing why I want
this extra term here do you see some
commonalities between the first line of
the second line I hope you see a lot of
commonalities it'll be a little more
obvious if I take this same line and I'm
gonna move everything over to line it up
slightly differently okay
so just pause for a second what you're
writing just so you can see what I'm
about to do don't where you have a
chance to keep on writing look up I'm
just gonna move everything along a
little bit by sort of one little note oh
my thing goes off the screen can you see
it
there's the arrow in the end the phone
turn okay in fact I'm gonna that's gonna
be so important I'm gonna get rid of
this and wrap up all of this stuff okay
now that'll give some time to write now
what have I done
it's the same terms but I've just kind
of moved them over so you can see them
lining up you okay with that so far what
I've lined up and not every term fits
but most of them do what I've lined up
is these identical terms from line one
to line two you okay with that the AR
and the AR AR squared AR squared and so
on okay so you can see all of these guys
that are identical so far so good
now what I want to do is take advantage
of the fact that because I have so many
things that are identical I can get rid
of all of those identical terms if I
bless you if I take one line and
subtract the entire next line let me say
that again I'm gonna take this whole
line and subtract every term from this
line are you okay with that this is a
bit like sites of simultaneous equations
you know when you're like solving by
elimination that's kind of what I'm
trying to do I'm trying to eliminate all
of these guys okay so I'm gonna do this
part slowly because I know there's a lot
to write right I'm going to include some
zeros to make my subtraction a bit
easier yeah adds your oh nothing changes
okay so I'm gonna do the first line take
away the second line first line take
away the second line okay and I'm gonna
do it
term by term so you can see it for me
this is just what happens when you take
the left-hand side of the first line and
you take away the left-hand side of the
second line so far so good
okay and I'm going to do it for every
single other term right here
the first pair of terms I take away zero
right first take away second here comes
the next pair again first take away
second are you starting to get a sense
of the pattern now right I'm gonna have
to keep on doing this for every time are
you getting the idea can I put the rest
of them on now okay
so when I do the entire line take away
the entire next line then this is what
you end up with okay I'm just like here
because I've got this down in the middle
I've got a dot dot dot in the middle
here okay but this is what we've got are
you all right with that I know that's a
lot but that's because I don't know how
many terms they were I just had to write
all of them okay now what's great about
this is how much of this collapses how
much of it just sort of disappears right
I'm all the zeros they're gone all these
things where I've matched up the card
they're all gone as well right so where
do we end up what actually gets left
behind
yep that a nothing pairs up with it to
cancel it out and then the other guy
that doesn't get cancer that is yeah a
RN so this is where we end up